[Music]
up there is pure energy in its raw
sporum
that's exactly what i need
wild honey
a nutritious calorie-packed hit of
energy
it's pretty special stuff
but getting it is never easy
oh
i'm getting stung all over
i just keep getting
nailed
by bees
my plan is simple i'm using this rope
ladder i've made
so i can position myself right next to
the entrance
i can hear him buzzing that is the
landing pad for the thousands of bees
that live inside this tree
where the honey is
cutting into here means i won't damage
the hive above oh yeah they're coming
you see them
they know i'm here
oh yeah they're coming out now
but this wood is like concrete
i'm just aggravating the bees
i have to try something different
they're coming out in force
i just have to reach inside
eyelids
just a few sticky handfuls are enough
[Music]
yeah
time to get out of here
[Music]
another day in the jungle
yeah
they're still everywhere in my hair
pain is a price worth paying
this could be my only food for days
so good
mmm
pure honey straight from the hive
this is amazing
[Music]
you